hey what's up guys it's rob today i'd
like to teach you how to make a paper
football these are really fun to flick
around or play with other people if
you're looking for something to do or a
game to play and at the end of the video
i will show you some different ways you
can flick them and some other things you
could do with them including
interlocking them so that you have
something like this and then you could
throw it sort of like a ninja star so
those are some of the things you could
do with them and what you're going to
need is a piece of printer paper or a
piece of loose leaf paper for this
tutorial i'm going to be using loose
leaf paper because i find that it makes
the folding a lot easier since the paper
is a little bit thinner
and some people have been asking me what
type of paper i use in my tutorials well
for the printer paper i'm using
standard letter size printer paper eight
and a half by eleven inches i think i
bought this somewhere uh possibly best
buy
and for the loose leaf paper i'm going
to be using college ruled eight inches
by ten and a half inches now if you have
something out of your notebook
like this and you'd like to rip a sheet
out that should work just fine
you're just going to want to remove that
little serrated edge on the end there so
once you have a piece of paper
preferably loose leaf paper you're ready
to begin so what you're going to want to
do is to hold the paper so that the
longer ends are horizontal and if you're
using loose leaf paper i like to put the
holes on top because when you fold it
down it will hide them if you put them
on the bottom they're going to be shown
it doesn't really matter but what you
want to do is take the top of the paper
and to fold it down to the bottom end of
the paper
and once you have the edges aligned
neatly
then you can make a crease along the top
of the paper
and then we're going to take the top end
once more and fold it down to the bottom
end of the paper
so just take it and fold it down to the
other end
just like that
and then you can make another crease
along the top
so you should have a piece of paper that
looks just like this
now we're going to take one end of the
paper and fold it across to the other
end of the paper
just like that
and you might want to do this on a flat
surface i like to hold it up to the
camera so you guys can see what i'm
doing so once you align it edge to edge
then you can kind of tug on it here
to round that off
and make a crease on the end here
okay so once you fold it like that then
we're going to open it
and then you just want to hold it
so that you have the piece of paper
vertically positioned just like that now
i'm just going to draw a horizontal line
on that fold which we just made
just so it's a little easier for you to
see
and then we're going to take the paper
and we're going to take the bottom half
of it
and we want to fold it to the left onto
that line so that this edge on the right
on the bottom right here lines up with
that that line i drew
so you want to fold it just like that to
the left and make a crease along the
bottom here
then we're going to take the bottom of
the paper and fold it straight up along
that line
and it's probably easier to do these
folds on a flat surface
and you want to make sure everything
stays nice and flat
after you make these new folds
so just make some creases along the
paper
and then you'll see we have some excess
paper here on the left and what you want
to do with this paper is you want to
fold it behind the model
on this line here that we have so you
want to fold it back all the way until
it comes around the other side
and then you want to make a crease on
the left side of the model
now what you're going to do with this
little excess paper is you're going to
fold it
where it meets this edge here so you
want to fold it to the left just like
that
and make a crease
then you can take the excess paper and
as you'll see we have a little bit of a
triangular pocket here
and you could just tuck this excess
paper right into that pocket
and just make sure everything is nice
and flat now we want to take the top of
the paper and we want to fold it
straight down along this line here where
the paper meets the top of this edge so
let me just draw a line
so that you can see where i'm talking
about
just fold the paper straight down along
that line so you want to take it
and fold it straight down
and then just make a crease along the
top of the paper
now if you hold the model if you flip it
around you'll see there's excess paper
that overhangs the model here what you
want to do is you just want to fold up
along this edge here now
so the paper kind of wraps around and
then just make a crease along the bottom
okay so now you can just open everything
back up
and then what we're going to do
you'll see this is the little the tip of
the paper which we kind of wrapped
around
the bottom of this we want to just fold
straight downwards on that fold now and
then just make another good crease
and remember this pocket here that we
had previously the triangular pocket
we're going to take the whole half
the top half of the model now and we're
going to tuck it into that triangular
pocket so you want to just open it
and you want to tuck the model
you want to tuck the rest of the paper
into that pocket
and then you want to make a really good
crease
along the outside of the paper here
so you should have a model that looks
just like this
then what we're going to do is we're
going to take this corner
and you want to fold it to the other
corner
straight along this edge here
so you want to just take the whole model
and just fold it in half
along that edge the paper gets a little
thick here but
the loose leaf paper definitely makes it
a lot easier to make this fold
you just want to fold it in half like
that
and make a really good crease along that
edge you might need to put it on the
table
and just push down really hard on it
and then you could open it back up
and what you want to do is you're going
to tuck
the whole
upper right part of the model into that
pocket as well
and it kind of helps if you round off
this part of the paper here so if you
make it a little bit round
and then you open this pocket
you can then tuck that corner in there
you see how it's bending a little bit so
just open this pocket
and tuck the corner of the paper in
and you want to push it until it's all
the way
[Applause]
inside that pocket
and you can open this a lot if you want
it's not going to damage anything
and then all you need to do
to just flatten out
the football on the table
and there you go you have finished your
paper football
okay so my favorite way to flick it is
to have it positioned just like this on
the table
now you can also hold it like this with
the point facing down
or you can even hold it like this with
the point facing away from you and flick
it i find that this way kind of hurts
your finger
this is my favorite way to flick it and
i think it goes the farthest this way
so
what you need to do is just hold it like
that with one finger on top of the
triangle and then you're just going to
basically flick it right in the middle
there
like that
now
if you're trying to basically play a
game with it you might want to have the
other person
hold their fingers up like for a field
goal
and that way you guys can try to aim
back and forth and see who can get the
most
points or something like that if you'd
like to join the footballs then what you
could do is just notice that the
football has
some openings or pockets on the side so
if you take other footballs and you try
to
slide them into those openings
you could then come up with some pretty
unique designs which you could then
throw or you can even try to flick
hey that worked out pretty well all
right guys thank you very much for
watching the video and if you enjoyed it
i ask that you please rate comment and
subscribe for further notification of my
videos uh some other ideas i have for
videos coming up are the origami ring
which i also promised i would make and
i'd also like to teach you guys the
fastest way in the world to tie your
shoes so instead of doing the loop
around all you need to do
something like that